hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
now before we get started I wanted to
give you fair warning the second game in
the series while it is not technically a
horror game it's actually a co-op
fighting okay I guess you would call it
but it's really gross
it's horrible in so many ways it's so
horrible that I actually consider it to
be a scary game so I'm giving you fair
warning if you're easily grossed out by
like body horror type stuff I mean it's
entertaining but it's it's gross but
I'll let you be the judge
so thank you and enjoy this is Emmys for
I don't know what it's about it may be a
horse like stylized game like that in
the background for years for years I've
been chasing this bastard alias alphabet
killer identity unknown
I know I'm closing in on this guy or
maybe that's just what he wants me to
think so many sleepless nights but let's
take s you know Chinese takeouts
I love rhymes sometimes I wonder if it's
really worth it we're not going to throw
away four years of work now oh I should
start searching towards the east and
wing of the building according to my
records that's where he should be
located just tab to view notebook just
in case I forget I'd like to write
myself little tidbits of reminders
imagining that I'm in a video game
okay alright
tab oh all right let's go this seems
like it's definitely the Raiden that's
radio is super annoying why send it to
the moon if it doesn't work
[Music]
not that annoying oh look blood death I
knew it I knew there'd be blood here
there's been a murder I have a birdie
song me hello
has anybody here seen a murder I'm
investigating snippy step II trippy
trappy on my bloody touch he would seize
anybody here
oh uh it's you
I think hello you just just gonna look
at me he's gonna look at me is that all
you're gonna do okay I guess what am i
doing Oh what the hell Oh
[Music]
someone turning out the light ey T's I
hope someone puts this right oh that's
you I can see you better all right
anyway
can I open the door no all right then
you carry on I don't know what I'm
supposed to do look at these okay okay
[Music]
okay I have no idea okay
I wish I could oh hi oh okay ah I guess
my good friend the mannequin all right
so you're pointing here right yeah all
right
oh hi hello is this is gonna be a
running theme here are we gonna have
just a bunch of mannequins is that where
we're gonna be dealing with ho or did it
I think ooh
meeting in the East Wing for CLA members
asked Jenny to make sure all
prerequisite documents make sure to
stock on coffee supplies call Kevin
Kevin goddamnit you get your ass in here
okay
oh hi how are you good to see you there
I love the zooms I have anyway are you
Jenny Jenny we need some coffee
can you call Kevin grades hello
still can't open this all right I do not
like the way your heads turn to me oh I
hate that okay so um hmm and you who
Kevin get your sweet ass in here Kevin
Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin
Kevin Kevin keV keV buddy
keV is this the coffee Oh
nine-one-one
okay so it's probably if I had to guess
the only four numbers that I saw were on
this yellow piece of paper and they said
four one five seven and
I knew anything about that that's
probably the code for one five seven
four one five seven better call Kevin
goddamn it Kevin you Kevin was that you
oh you scamp oh you scamp Kevin whoa
whoa yo yo yo okay sorry I'm so sorry
about that
pardon me did you have places to go
Kevin
is that you Kevin you sack of [ __ ] get
your ass back in here Oh
so help me Kevin oh you wanna play a
game of peekaboo I know where to play a
game of peekaboo hug - do somebody
didn't wipe probably anyway ignore that
press e to pick up gun what if I don't
want to press space to equip gun hurry
what if I didn't hurry well it doesn't
seem like it
let me gonna go look at you Kevin that's
what you get where's my coffee damn it
all right Kevin Oh someone's ashamed
someone can't look me in the eye
well we can't look anybody in the eye
anymore all right hang on Janice Jana no
you listen nothing personal about this
what she's like are you funny enemy no
no I never do oh you got me as soon as
you don't look oh you know tomb huh
boop-boop boop-boop boop-boop she look
at me cross-eyed red all right anyway so
yeah okay boop-boop okay got it
cool well anyway what uh what do we got
going on here Kevin you got my coffee
you son of a tit you better get your
bass out bat bass bass bass four one
five seven better get two goddamn Kevin
okay
is there another secret why are we
outside no whatever
Oh hum Oh hope that it's a course like
grandpa bumper bumper and forever oh boy
oh boy okay what what in the world there
next stump still turn no they don't okay
oh it's like I'm surprising that more
than they're surprising me oh wait okay
sorry point point point point point
point no okay okay
anyway I reload do I lose the night
I don't know I can't do math alright so
I need oh well that's ominous and
glowing hello
oh I can't oh do you believe me eat no I
don't actually doesn't work it doesn't
work doesn't work all right well I the
only the only thing I knew is oh hey hey
there
may I see yeah okay so there's Oh check
faulty mains come up with better things
book mariachi band where's that mariachi
did I just shoot the Mariachi band I
hope I didn't where would if I was a
code oh oh
clippity-clop whoops okay well there dad
okay whoa what did I activate what the
hell oh I see a skin purse camper out
there someone's this can't be okay
I have those we can I have those could I
have those please that sounds pretty
good all right well none of these soda
machines work and I activated something
or other
now somebody needs a an ass whoopin you
want to run that by me again
what'd you say what'd you say to me
you'll run that by me again
but this isn't about you this is about
me Oh apparently it's about you okay
well that was fun
all right anyway excuse me tripped on
those all right
okay this is a tea party what the hell
happened here
wait you ruined everything you prepared
a tea party just for you now we and now
the trade teas gone cold
had you been on time no one would have
gotten hurt but I found you in your
house while you were sleeping you excuse
me excuse me excuse me excuse me you you
are your books are crap fix them your
blocks are crap you lied to your CEO
about getting the gun survived serviced
knock not okay what all right are you
trying to be creepy all right okay you
broke in and watch me sleep
hope you like my boner in the power back
on again why did I oh I don't know I
know you didn't even look at me that
time on the phone there you go you're
dead now
bumbum alright okay
we're did it wahoo what's next
who wants to fight me next come on I'm
ready for you Oh
Oh bum bum bum sorry were you just
trying to relax you're not even looking
at me
what do I care anymore okay that's
barricaded Oh dark oh well oh those four
shots for headshots I got him those easy
enough
[Music]
well done DJ Haines I don't wanna I
don't want to admonish it in any way
those those fun a little silly but
totally fun well done I I can't really
fault you at all can't fault you at all
for that one that was just plain old fun
it was a little silly but I made him
sillier than it actually was that was
fun it was fine it was totally fine all
right
so I've got another one let's just let's
just roll straight through to the other
one that I have here so yeah about this
one okay so um this is a normal human
face simulator and okay yep oh my god
[Music]
this is just oh my good
oh my god
is so visceral I saw this I saw this and
it was just like holy [ __ ] I don't like
the inhale oh it's so sad when it's just
one person playing I mean to be bad if
two people were playing but oh my god
[Music]
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get banned it is
a horrible Oh got your nose I guess ha
ha the crunching oh the crunching oh my
god what am I still going it Oh
it's also not good at this like these
twins
they're going at it for some reason
still what's the point
who made this who made this and with
what in mind oh my goodness Oh your lips
are so loose oh why am I still playing
yeah the sounds are horrible this says
are horrible oh why why are you still
watching this oh well we've already
started down the path so we might as
well see how deep the rabbit-hole really
goes huh oh my goodness oh my goodness
great oh my god that is just Dorothy do
oh oh oh oh what a funny joke yeah I
know
ho ho ho that's why this game is just a
normal normal everyday human face
simulator game everyone knows they're oh
my god talk about a precision
strike holy [ __ ] uh how do you win how
do you lose oh my god oh oh oh I'm gonna
be sick I'm gonna be sick I shouldn't
eaten all that cheese oh well there you
have it there you have a normal human
face simulator though oh well anyway hey
you guys want to go again here we go all
right there we go let's do this and he's
gonna munch you gonna crunchy munch yeah
crunch crunch crunch goes hi Jed how you
doing I'm pretty good never how about
you oh you know just taking it one day
at a time you know yeah I know how it'd
be you don't need to tell me twice
well I'll tell you again as many times
as you need cuz I love you brother
I love you brother
- you are a shining example of what it
means to be an upstanding citizen wow
that's so kind of you to say how about
you and I go see that new Avengers movie
I'd like that very much
and I could get a large popcorn too
crunchy pound oh yeah better than you
crunching on my face right oh [ __ ]
Packard practical joke for a second
there I thought you were really gonna
crunch me
okay we're out looks good uh
tonk gal I don't like that sound of it
that was not good but this looks like it
might be pretty good guy ooh the
animations are nice that was pretty
impressive actually okay so my
flashlight isn't working I'm trapped in
a cavern of some kind in the Philippines
oh now it's working oh it's still dark
though I can't see Garbo oh I like this
I'm not one for keeping a journal but I
feel like if I don't write this down
it's gonna gnaw on me for the rest of
the week there's something down here
with us
I'm sure of it at first I thought it was
just the bats but I've never seen bats
that big before
it's Batman maybe all the extra hours I
signed up for I've started to get to me
I haven't told the others yet I don't
want the boss to fire me for starting
trouble
I could assume din and zoomed out okay
that's fine
okay so there's something uh something
down here with us is what you're saying
needs fuel well handy dandy about that
where are we gonna find some goddamn
shoe whoa okay hi Vanessa
how you doing wife of mine you feeling
uh feeling okay I don't want these
symbols all about but all right
okay okay all right well that that
distort that oh I don't remember that
being there oh wow all right okay I can
read this I never wanted to believe in
you and those like you if I did how
could I ever hope to feel safe again but
now after what I've seen I have no
choice
Alejandro says that you are real and I
believe him he also says that we need to
show you respect and that is what I
intend to do okay so I got it show
respect by lighting these candles my
grandma used to tell me stories about
that thing why would your grandma tell
you stories about a minute an angle what
is that what is that oh oh what a lovely
mysterious white substance you have in
your bowl my grandma used to have one of
these in your living room
they're supposed to be protectors well I
think your grandma was into some weird
[ __ ] like I don't mean to call your
grandma weird and stuff but it's so
heavy
maybe because it's full of gas I mean
that's the ideal right what else what
else would be there why what else would
it be so heavy yeah that - should do it
dance down right there that's you dude
okay so I am right there
there's caution here there's caution
there they're elevators there and other
generators over there okay all right
seems pretty straightforward just don't
make too many left turns is the long the
short of it whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what the [ __ ] hell was that okay let
me hang on yeah
I can't everything's at maximum yeah I'm
just gonna crank it up for you guys
you're gonna get the full effect
[Music]
Oh employee of the month did that say
employee of the month
oh one headlight per employee only oh I
thought that I thought that was employee
of the month gets a headlight all the
other scuzz get to walk around in the
darkness feel around with your hands why
is that yeah we got a serious demon
alert going on here
the man angle and the tangle it takes to
to man and angle all right I don't feel
comfortable in any way shape or form
in fact why are you doing that why are
you doing that
well that's happening what am I looking
at who's there something in the darkness
you were doing a thing you were doing a
wibbly-wobbly thing well huh come on
come on
[Music]
oh I can't see
what Oh Oh what the hell
can I have more batteries please I can't
see I can barely see anything oh how
nice you spared me when I saw you all
those years ago
I can only hope you'll do the same now
okay
let's light some candles why are these
pictures even in here is that a man and
angle and a pregnant lady is your
grandma into some kinky or [ __ ] then I
thought she was okay so I don't know I
don't know which way I went five have a
feeling wasn't the right way because I'm
out of batteries I got no batteries
I got no nothing falling rocks I got a
whole lot of nothing over here there's
no lights there's no nose dick deadly as
dick doodlee it was their battery over
here or something a rosary that's not
gonna help me god I wish I had batteries
what is this
attention all workers I'm aware of the
reason why this month's quota wasn't
been filled I understand your concerns
but what you should be worried about is
keeping your jobs we have done what we
can to prevent anything from happening
it and it seems to be worth it working
what matters now is that we produce
results if you're not up to the task we
have no use for you at this company
overseer mark Chiquito right okay fine
dude can I have another battery just one
more I I feel like this is why I don't
know what's happening I couldn't say
anything I'm a battery dare Kimmi put it
in shove it in
hoots has bid themselves why why how why
why
oh my god Oh Oh what was that what why
oh I'm guessing I'm not supposed to go
there something's bad over there
something bad okay I'm not gonna go that
way
okay back I'm in light I'd see something
uh I don't like this excuse your
language here
honey honey oh where is this and oh I
circled back somehow wait a minute okay
so this is where I was running out of
batteries anyway so if I if I go through
here
I need batteries are garbage but if I go
through here there's remember there was
like oh man if I could just remember
what the map was I couldn't keep quiet
about it anymore the others deserve to
know I've seen it multiple times in this
mind now closer and closer each time my
co-workers need to know to be careful
and to stay in the light Joshua didn't
want to believe me at first he's young
and he didn't grow up with the stories
like the rest of us did but he's seen it
too said it almost got to him yesterday
now that even Joshua's seen it I know
for certain that my eyes weren't
deceiving me huh okay
well good for you more batteries yes
please okay at least I got some
confidence going forward the batteries
know a tight crevasse of nothing there's
nothing in here this is a place to get
lost if my light goes out okay let's try
down here which way did I come from I
wonder why these cables lead good
question maybe you shouldn't ask so many
questions
okay oh that's ominous oh did I circle
back oh god damn it
oh god let me consult the map oh my god
I'm such a fool I thought it was gonna
be easy
turns I was gonna be hard okay so I'm
trying to go straight down
unless I'm thinking about this the wrong
way because maybe this no this is that's
gotta be kidding
maybe maybe I'm wrong with this all
right whatever I'm just gonna dive in
hope for the best if I can find my way
through I can find my way through if I
can't I can't but let's follow these
wires like she was saying wires wires
where's where's where's where's where's
where's wires wires wires okay this led
back to here somehow I circled all the
way back from here I don't know how he
did that wires wires wires wires wires
wires wires the wires end the wires end
here but there's another way ah ha ha
have I been here
have I seen this the reports you've sent
me are more than troubling you're not
producing nearly as much mag manganese
as your monthly quota requires and do
this I cannot give you full pay well
you're telling me about the workers is a
problem you need to fix something I
assumed you were capable of when you
assume this position if there really is
something in those mines you simply have
to drive it out if you don't there are
plenty of people willing to take your
place and solve it in your stead
consider this your first and only
warning if the issue isn't resolved and
the quota isn't filled for the next
month the next lever you receive will be
one of termination wow what a nice and
understanding CEO man so shocking that
he wouldn't be more compassionate given
that he's a CEO can't believe that okay
one light per employee there's another
one okay well good for me they all need
fuel apparently okay so there's got to
be a fuel tank nearby for this one right
due to health hazards of overexposure to
manganese all workers must wear safety
master in mining I don't want any
trouble with mr. manga but and I you
don't want to lose your jobs either this
is non-negotiable
overseer all right mr. overseer if that
is your real name I'm gonna find some
goddamn gasoline Oh
okay is this going somewhere Oh lovely
lighter up I guess cuz this is probably
a good idea to light these all on fire
as soon as I see him Oh people bound up
this happen none of this makes any sense
no it does not it makes no sense at all
I don't understand it and neither should
you hello nice Beefalo any code written
on it no okay essential oil lavender
essential oil though this is but now
there that I knew there into some crazy
[ __ ] that got lavender essential oil
Hawk can't believe it alright there's
got to be gas I'll take those yes please
there's got to be gas somewhere around
here right gotta be i see the creature
more often now it always appears in the
corner of my eye and i hear when the
machines go quiet
I think it's calling me I can't remember
the last time I was able to work in
peace whenever I try to I fear that it
will sneak up on me I don't dare door
disrespected my Lola always said that if
these things can't be avoided they need
to be a piste I hope I've done enough oh
I'm sure you've done enough some kind of
like sacrifice of some sort probably if
it still works maybe you can but you're
on the wrong side why did that say it
over here okay so I still got to find
gasps no gasps anywhere oh but batteries
oh god those are easy to miss
okay then in here hmm it's probably just
gonna tell me that I need gas once I get
here come on reload the batteries it's
not that bad come on don't be such a
baby about it connected to generator B
it doesn't work all right yeah I gotta
find gas now where would there be gas I
don't have a good mental map of this
place so I'm just gonna be wandering
around for a good bit no I've read this
yeah read that okay so I've been there
oh hello sneaky sneaky sneaky
okay so there's gotta be there's gotta
be gas somewhere come on if somebody's
got gas whose tell me I don't want to be
wandering around forever
oh what a bunch of baloney maybe maybe I
can maybe if I go back I can pick up the
other gas canister and I could just like
I don't know maybe I could double it up
and co-opt one to the other
I don't even know where that place was
where there was horrible monstrosity
what why why whoa why why what [ __ ]
you're just gonna say [ __ ] about that
just like that's a [ __ ] of a moment
that's just like oh [ __ ] I got my ass
eating out
wait no hang on that's not what I meant
not not like that that's that's not it
is that a gas scanner is that a gas
barrel that's a guy's anyway no I mean
um God my God my ass eating it still
sounds bad got my you know what I mean
you know what I mean so I'm horrible
some horrible job yeah let's go with
that just pretend I said something that
made sense there you're here this leads
to here oh here it goddamnit here it is
okay time for the slow walk back got it
okay we're good we're good
we're good here we go sometimes these
moments where it's just like you got to
take the thing and haul it all the way
back like that just sucks all the fun
AVI
the whole endeavor yeah I it's okay it's
alright I'm going as fast as I can
skedaddle apparently I'll get Oh
[Music]
gonna get my ass eating out again
probably anyway what was that I have no
idea I don't know I've it exploded your
face there we go all better now time to
get in the elevator and giddy Audi if
you can hear me go to the elevator oh
yeah I'm sure that'll work
oh oh whoa hi okay
alright well then I don't think
Vanessa's going to say
boom Oh
that was it all right well there you go
then okay not bad not bad I'd say I mean
a lot of people worked on that it was
really impressive from the beginning but
if you think about it the only game
mechanic there was was find the gas can
that was the only game mechanic and
there needs to be a better game mechanic
then find the gas can but it still
wasn't bad I feel like it could have
been more though I feel like he could
have been a lot more like there was a
lot IV assalatu work done in the
animations like the art of it the detail
of it I just feel like there could have
been a lot more than just you have
flashlight it dark find gas and that's
it so potential but I feel like it could
be better so that was three scary games
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you have more scary games that you
want me to play put them in the comments
and I've put links to all these games in
the description as well thank you
everybody that made it and thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more scary games that I
played I've got a full playlist there's
over 200 videos of me playing various
scary games in there I'll put a link to
that in the description as well and
check out some of the other scary games
that I played on this channel as well
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]